hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein super
gesundes rezept viele haben mich gefragt
weil er jetzt das neue jahr gestartet
ist kannst du vielleicht mal gesunde
frühstück alternativen machen ich
persönlich esse selber gerne immer
morgens eine scheibe brot mit aufstrich
oder käse und das kann man auch gerne
mal austauschen durch das was wir heute
machen nämlich leckeres ein weißbrot
aber nicht dieses casting gebrochene
weissbrodt was nicht im supermarkt
sondern wie gesagt süße keine fladen und
die schmecken unglaublich lecker und
gehen auch sehr schnell
und das gute ist wir brauchen nur vier
zutaten mich euch jetzt zeige
wir benötigen die habe ich hier in
eiweiß und eigelb getrennt außerdem
magerquark salz und sesam und die eier
habe ich bereits getrennt weil wir
wollen das eiweiß steif schlagen damit
es richtig schön fluffig wird das brot
und das mache ich jetzt auch ich geb das
eiweiß zusammen mit der krise in meine
schüsse
wichtig ist dass die schüssel wirklich
frei ist und dann ganz einfach mit dem
handrührgerät aufschlagen
[Musik]
was macht jetzt schön steigt jetzt nehme
ich mal eine neue schüssel und das werde
ich nicht ausspielen den schritt spare
ich mir jetzt einfach die neue schüssel
eigelb mit dem magerquark und dann wird
das auch nur ganz kurz verrührt so das
hat jetzt auch noch ein paar sekunden
gedauert und als nächstes nämlich die
eiweiße und hebt sich mit dem teig
scheibe vorsichtig unter
[Musik]
so der teig ist fertig den ofen habe ich
vorgehabt das ist ganz wichtig hat sie
noch jeden fall vor auf 150 grad ober
unterhitze jetzt habe ich hier meinen
backblech mit einem mit einer dauer back
folie können natürlich auch ein
backpapier nehmen und ich gibt es noch
ein bisschen wachsen spray drauf damit
dass nachher nicht an klebt und hier und
jetzt verteilen wir den teig einfach
drauf mit ein bisschen abstand
[Musik]
so detailliert in sechs geteilt und
jetzt gebe ich noch sesam um darauf was
auch super lecker schmeckt ist
schwarzkümmel könnt ihr auch gerne mal
versuchen
so und jetzt wann hat das ganze in den
ofen wie gesagt 150 grad ober unterhitze
vorgeheizt für 20 bis 25 minuten und
wichtig ist achtet nicht auf dem minuten
anzahl die ich euch denn es kann sein
dass sie bei euch hat 18 minuten schon
fertig sind oder nach 26 27 minuten
jeder offenbar anders und ich sage euch
aber in jedem fall wie lange es bei mir
gedauert hat
[Musik]
die proteine fladenbrote haben jetzt 20
minuten bei mir gedauert und wir sind
unglaublich weiß also sind natürlich
erst mal hoch die sind ein bisschen
dicker und wenn sie aus dem ofen kommen
dann flachen sie ab und dann kann man
sie auch richtig schön angenehm belegen
mit dem was im metropol wie peter genau
und ihr könnt gerne auch daraus burger
machen auch eine coole idee also einfach
den burger partie gerne und falafel
partie ist auch eine coole idee
trautmann müssen manchmal auch filme
oder aber zu tun mit thunfisch stunden
ist das nun richtige protein bombe cool
auf jeden fall ist er geschmacklich
superlecker natürlich ein bisschen
lustig aber ich mag das also wenn ihr
euer wird um network dann ist es absolut
das richtige rezept für euch die
konsistenz ist super weich ganz auch
gern nur zeigen sehr weich und ich werde
euch die zutaten natürlich wie immer
unten in die infobox schreiben wir
können wir gerne kommentar da lassen was
ihr noch sehen möchte und dann freue ich
mich wenn ihr meinen kann kostenlos
abonniert und dann sehen wir uns auch
beim nächsten mal auf die skizzen
tschüss